I don't know about you but I just can't
get enough of the non-canonical gospels
they're just so fascinating in
themselves they offer so many questions
and what ifs they Nuance our
understanding of the earliest days of
the largest religion in the world and
they also teach us how religions and
traditions like this develop over time
and Inc conversation with its time and
place in previous episodes we've
explored the gospels of Thomas Judah and
Mary and since Christmas season is
approaching again I thought it would be
fun to dive into another one of the Lost
often termed quote unquote Gnostic
Gospels and this time we're going to
look into the one that has by far the
greatest name of them all the gospel of
Phillip a very strange and complex text
that often defy a clear categorization
into you know belonging to one group or
another and which has themes that are
sometimes very familiar to us but at
other times shockingly different from
what we used to in other Christian text
so let's dive into the gospel of
[Applause]
Phillip a bit of self-promotion before
we start um have you ever wondered what
all the music on this channel comes from
well actually the majority of the music
is actually made by me and a lot of that
music is available on Spotify and all
these different platforms and stores and
today I'm actually releasing a new
single called ismus with my project zeni
so if you're interested in my music and
the kind of kind of music that I make
then definitely go check out that song
it's on Spotify it's on my other YouTube
channel Philip Holm uh it's in most of
those places where you'll find Know
music in the streaming where you can
stream music so please if you feel so
inclined go check out the song if you
like it then you know spread the word
share it um let me know what you think
of the song uh and yeah um back to the
video the gospel of philli is a
so-called non-canonical gospel which
means it is a text that was copied
spread and read by certain groups of
early Christianity but which did not
make it into the canonical scriptures of
the Bible or the New Testament as a
result many of these texts eventually
lost popularity and were lost to history
for Millennia existing only as myths and
mentions in other
writings that is until the 1940s when
the so-called noamar library was found
in Egypt a treasure chove of ancient
text that had survived in caves and
which for the first time gave us first
handwritings from Lost groups like The
gnostics the valentinians and the
thomasine
Christians this discovery is what has
revolutionized our understanding of the
diversity of early Christianity and
given us some truly fascinating text
some of which we have already explored
on this channel such as the Gospel of
Thomas and the Gospel of Mary and among
this fascinating group of texts there is
also the mysterious Gospel of Phillip a
text which can be hard to categorize but
which has become famous worldwide by
showing up in pop culture such as in The
DaVinci Code its Fame primarily stems
from a certain juicy section or quote
which we will get to later but first of
all what is this text who wrote it and
what's it all about well there are some
significant uncertainties and Mysteries
surrounding this text like many other
texts from the noamar library is written
in Coptic the Egyptian language but has
been translated from an original Greek
so we think that it was written in Greek
originally and because of certain users
of syc terms some Scholars think that it
might have been written in Syria
possibly sometime in the late 2nd
Century so compared to some of the other
texts we have explored this one appears
pretty late in other words the text is
structured in a pretty interesting way
um it's called a gospel but it's not a
gospel in the traditional sense as we
know the gospels from the New Testament
in that it is not a an account of the
life of Jesus and his teachings in that
way at all uh neither is it like the
Gospel of Thomas which is just a
collection of sayings by Jesus instead
the gospel of philli is like just a
collection of paragraphs and and short
sections about various different topics
um sometimes that this gospel can feel
kind of disjointed um you know a theme
between the paragraphs can be very you
know it it can be hard to see any any
kind of clear thread between them but
there are certain themes that recur and
when you sort of dive deeper into you
can see some of these these themes
recurring and that there is a kind of
internal um there's an internal logic to
the text but it's very much a kind of
collection of different paragraphs and
short um sayings and and and teachings
sometimes very esoteric teachings and so
on Jesus shows up in the text but there
are only about 15 sayings of Jes Jesus
in the entire thing like I said the
individual sections seem pretty
disconnected sometimes albe it perhaps
unified by certain themes which has led
many scholars to consider that it might
not be originally a unified work but
rather precisely that a collection of
quotes that have been taken from other
sources as for who wrote it that is also
a point of contention and quite a
mystery it wasn't written by the
disciple philli of course and Philip is
only mentioned once in the text rather
Philip might be a kind of composite
figure according to scapel that
symbolically represents the teaching of
this gospel in some way it's clear from
the text that it did not come from the
group that we sometimes call the Proto
Orthodox in other words those Christians
whose theology would eventually end up
as the
mainstream instead the text shares many
features with various other groups
making it hard to attribute it to any
single one many have argued that its
doctrines are rather Thomas sign in
nature thus perhaps coming from the same
group repres presented by the the Gospel
of Thomas um on the other hand there are
many other features that are decidedly
so-called Gnostic in nature as well as
others that are more valentinian the
role of Mary in the text also reminds us
of the Gospel of Mary and how it
portrays her so the text could originate
with any of these groups really or
perhaps given the nature of the
scripture perhaps it contains bits and
pieces from multiple sources the most
popular consensus is that the text
primarily functioned within a
valentinian context but it's definitely
still open for discussion the
valentinians were a certain group of
early Christians uh founded by a guy
called valentinus in Rome was a pretty
prominent figure was actually up for
becoming the bishop of Rome in other
words the pope but uh sort of just
missed out on on that um position uh and
they became known for their very unique
doctrines they are closely connected to
the so-called gnostics um or the sethian
gnostics which is what I refer to as
gnostics usually um there are similarity
in teachings with Gnostic but they're
also quite different in other ways so
it's it's hard to sort of just equate
the two um but so yeah that's the
valentinians it's an important early
group of of Christians that had
significant differences in their sort of
doctrines and ideas compared to the
so-called Proto Orthodox which would
become the mainstream or Orthodox later
on so what does this gospel say well in
a general sense we could categorize it
as a kind of esoteric text or at least a
text concerned with esotericism and
esoteric doctrines there's a kind of
dichotomy presented between those who
are in the no s to say the ones that
have access to the true doctrines and
interpretations of the Bible the ingroup
in this case and the other the apostolic
Christians who are misled and
misinterpret scripture and Jesus by
reading things too literally this other
quot unquote misled group clearly
represents the so-called Proto Orthodox
who are misappropriating the message of
Jesus Jus they are even referred to in a
derogatory way as Hebrews in the text
quote some say Mary conceived by the
Holy Spirit they are wrong they do not
know what they're saying when did a
woman ever conceive by a woman Mary is
the Virgin whom no power defiled it is a
great anathema to the Hebrews who are
the apostles and Apostolic people so by
saying that you know when did a woman
ever conceive by a woman um they're
commenting on the fact that the Holy
Spirit grammatically
is is female right so that the spirit
would be a female that impregnates a
female and that sort of makes no sense
that's the point that's being made here
so already this indicates what kind of
people the text was aimed at one of the
groups of Christians at the time that
were concerned with gnosis or true
knowledge as the way to
Salvation now this doesn't mean that it
was written by the gnostics as in these
Seth the agnostics but that it shares
that common doctrine that we find in
many non-canonical Gospels including
those by the gnostics in other words
that salvation comes through the true
knowledge or gnosis that Jesus taught
and not necessarily through his death on
the cross and his resurrection in fact
the text seems like the gnostics and
valentinians to hold to what is known as
dotism in terms of their christology
this means that they believe that Jesus
wasn't actually human at all but fully
Divine and that it only appeared like he
had a human body quot Jesus took them
all stealthily
for he did not appear as he was but he
appeared as one that could not be seen
but to each of these he appeared he
appeared to the great as great he
appeared to the small as small he
appeared to the angels as an angel and
to humans as a human this also means
that the death and suffering on the
cross doesn't play a major role in this
theology in the way that it would in
mainstream Christianity instead just
like in the Gospel of Thomas or Mary and
the Gnostic Gospels it's all about
knowledge gnosis quot the one who has
knowledge of the truth is free but the
free person does not sin for the one who
sins is the slave to sin knowledge is
the way to Salvation that is knowledge
of our true selves and in that self
knowledge become United not only to that
higher self but with Christ and the
Divine itself meline scapel says quote
one of the major themes of the Gospel of
philli is the reunification of Soul and
Spirit in a Heavenly Union that realizes
the identification of the Soul with its
true self this theme of Union is a
recurring theme in the text and it is
always in conversation with a kind of
inherent Duality that runs through the
entire thing first of all we seem to
find references to the
characteristically Gnostic dualistic
cosmology so in the wider category that
is often referred to as Gnostic although
I am skeptical and careful with this
term since it is a modern categorization
we find it Rec curring cosmology where
there is a clear distinction between the
physical material world and the
spiritual Divine World referred to by
The sethians Who are the ones I refer to
as gnostics again as the ploma or
entirety in fact the physical world and
the body is even seen as something very
dirty and evil as a kind of prison that
needs to be escaped this is indeed an
overarching theme in many of these
schools that are sometimes clumsily
referred to as Gnostic including the
sethians the marianites and the
valentinians although there are of
course also nuances and differences
among them regarding this too this
cosmology has a dramatic tale about the
true hidden God which is called The
Invisible Spirits by the sethians and
the father by the valentinians from
which emanates a number of different
eons or eternities Divine principles
representing different attributes like
wisdom logos truth Etc at some point
though one of these eons often the one
called Sophia wisdom conceived in secret
of another kind of being of her own
which becomes a deformed creature that
is cast out of the Divine ploma this
ignorant sometimes evil or at the very
least sort of unrelentingly just being
is referred to with names like the Demi
urge meaning the Craftsman yalo or
saklas and he is the creator of the
physical world along with his archons or
rulers in other words the physical world
that we live in was not created by the
true God but by this ignorant pseudo
deity who of course created a flawed and
evil world to be escaped this is also
identified as the god of the Hebrew
Bible or Old Testament who gives you
know the Ten Commandments to Moses and
so on and we find clear traces of these
doctrines in the gospel of philli for
example quote the world came about
through a blunder for the one who
created it wanted to create it
imperishable and Immortal he failed and
he did not not achieve the objective for
the imperishability of the world never
came to be and the imperishability of
the one who made the world did not exist
clearly referring to the Demi urge and
his flawed creation but there's also
talk in the text about another kind of
Duality namely the inherent oppositions
in the world that create tension and
strife and this Duality is perhaps
primarily represented in the text uh
through the imagery of the male and the
female quote if the woman had not
separated from the man she would not
have died along with the man his
separation became the beginning from
death for this reason Christ came so
that he might rectify the division that
came about from the beginning and again
join the two and so that those who have
died in the division he might give life
and join them the world is full of such
oppositions and dualities not only male
and female but good and bad up and down
inside and outside Etc the perfect human
the principle of humanity which exists
in the ploma was androgynous and it is
only in this world that the human is
separated into male and female this
reunion of male and female also probably
refers to a reunion of Soul and Spirit
PS and pneuma in Greek to their original
State of Union in the True Divine self
of the human at the same time this might
also be a reference or certainly seems
to be connected to the common idea in
Gnostic cosmology that the Divine eons
in the ploma are usually conceived of as
existing in male female pairs but just
like in many other so-called Gnostic
texts if we can call this one that
there's an emphasis on the ugliness of
this world the prison from which we must
escape unlike the other Christians who
interpret scripture literally and
misunderstand Christ's message and the
nature of the world the true Community
knows the esoteric truths and aim to
escape the world and body instead
clothing themselves with a body of light
and live out a spiritual ual existence
quote this world is a corpse eater all
things that are eaten die as well truth
is a life eater for this reason none of
those nourished by the truth will die
Jesus came from that place and he
brought nourishment from there to those
who desired he gave life so that they
might not die like we said this is
achieved through the teachings of Jesus
particularly the true esoteric teachings
confer to select people and involves
some kind of Union of dualities and
ultimately a union with the Divine
itself in some way these dualities that
we have talked about male and female Pia
and Puma should be United once again
quot while the union dwells in this
world as male and female the place that
is strong and weakness in the entirety
the image of the Union is different
although we refer to them by these names
but the others exist they are exalted
above every name that is named and they
are exalted above the mighty for where
there is strength there those chosen for
power dwell they are not different
things but both of them are this one
single thing this talk of the reunion of
the Opposites is one of the recurring
themes in the text and sometimes takes
on romantic and even erotic imagery
indeed following these themes of male
and female uniting one of the most
characteristic terms and Concepts in the
text is the idea of marriage and the
so-called Bridal chamber quote but the
woman is joined to her husband in the
bridal chamber but those who have joined
in the bridal chamber will no longer be
separated these references have puzzled
Scholars what does this Bridal chamber
refer to is it some kind of symbolic
language for some kind of Union with the
Divine or is it referring to something
more practical some kind of ritual maybe
in fact one of the most striking aspects
of this text is that it seems to mention
some kind of sequence of of sacraments
even like some kind of ritual or rituals
in some way now we don't know anything
really about Gnostic or valentinian
rituals like how the valentinians
actually practice their form of
Christianity but in this text there
seems to be a mention of some kind of
sequence of rituals quote the Lord did
everything in a mystery a baptism and a
crism and a Eucharist and a Redemption
and a bridal chamber not only is this
striking in the sense of using baptism
and Eucharist as sacraments or rituals
which are certainly more associated with
Orthodox Christianity which this text
and those like it seem to reject so
strongly although it seems pretty clear
that they interpret these rituals in
some different ways but it's also
striking in invoking this Bridal chamber
among such rituals seemingly indicating
that it too involves some kind of
practice maybe even some kind of sexual
one the idea that these quote unquote
Gnostic groups performed some kind of
sexual rituals was often used as a kind
of argument by their enemies to
discredit the movement for example in
his classic text against the heresies
irus says quote for some of them prepare
a bridal chamber and perform a sort of
Mystic right pronouncing certain
expressions with those who are being
initiated and affirm that it is a
spiritual marriage which is celebrated
by them after the likeness of the
conjunctions above we simply don't know
exactly what this Bridal chamber thing
actually means in this text um the
gospel mentions it several times it's
one of the most recurring themes in the
entire text um and it seems also to
indicate that it is the sort of highest
achievement the highest spiritual
achievement on this you know path or in
this tradition or whatever they actually
use a kind of allegory in the text
comparing these sacraments these rituals
with the temple in Jerusalem which has
sort of um increasing or sort of maybe
descending or ascending levels of of of
Holiness right so so the first baptism
is sort of the outer courts of the
temple and then crism is like you go
into the next um room and then further
and further in and the bridal chamber is
represented by the holy of holies right
this the holiest part of the temple
where only the high priest could enter
and where the you know not of course in
Jerusalem but where in other places like
the actual image of the God would be
housed in in this most inner sanctum
right so the bridal chamber seems in
this Al
is like the the the most holy the most
sacred uh and
profound um peak of of the spiritual you
know maybe experience or path or
whatever is going on here I think that
this imagery certainly has something to
do with Divine Union the whole text
talks about the dichotomy of male and
female and how these dualities are to be
unified and imagery of kissing and
marriage are clear indications of the
male and female uniting a simp symbol of
the marriage and Union of the Divine
ploma with the sexual act in the bridal
chamber being the ultimate consummation
of that Unity it seems that the bridal
chamber thus represents perhaps the
highest mystical experience a kind of
Union with Christ or with God which
represents the end of the journey it is
possible though that this may have also
been some kind of a right at the same
time as many passages and outside
sources seem to indicate so this is the
ultimate aim of the practitioner to turn
away from the material world embody and
somehow reach a kind of unification with
his true self in the Divine realm quote
there is no other way that someone will
be able to produce for himself this
Grace unless he should clothe himself in
the perfect light and also become the
perfect light this is how one becomes
free and it's the true meaning of the
resurrection of course a group that view
the material world in this way wouldn't
hold the idea that the dead will be
physically resurrected at the end of
time instead true Resurrection happens
spiritually and in fact can take place
in this life quote what is the
resurrection it is necessary for the
image to rise through the image it is
necessary for the bridal chamber and the
image to come through the image into
truth that is the restoration and quote
those who say they will die first and
then rise are in error if they do not
first receive the resurrection while
they are alive when they die they will
not receive
anything in other words the resurrection
of the Dead is something that takes
place here in this life and spiritually
it is the Awakening to the Divine Life a
resurrection from being dead as in being
in this false um maybe evil or at least
sort of flawed world and body to
Awakening and being resurrected restored
in the Divine realm which is our true
home that is the true Resurrection and
only then will we receive you know our
reward when we when our body dies
eventually these are all of course
fascinating and striking themes but the
most famous aspect of this gospel by far
is of course the way that it talks about
the relationship between Jesus and Mary
Magdalene right um it's it's really
fascinating stuff um Mary just like in
the Gospel of Mary the gospel of philli
seems to portray her as being somehow
the favorite disciple of Jesus that
she's the sort of foremost disciple whom
he liked more than anyone else and who
whom he gave sort of the deepest truth
or the most full truth to in some way
the text mentions three different Maries
but indicates that one is quite special
quote three women always walked with the
master Mary his mother his sister and
Mary of magdala who is called His
companion for Mary is the name name of
his sister his mother and his companion
what does the author actually mean by
the word companion here is it simply
something equivalent to disciple or
companion in that sense well a section
later on seems to clarify this and makes
a statement that may appear shocking and
controversial to many quote the
companion of the savior is Mary of
magdala the Savior loved her more than
all the disciples and he used to kiss
her often on her and here we have
perhaps one of the most frustrating
lacunas in history the very last word in
this sentence is missing so we don't
know what it is that Jesus used to kiss
many including Marvin Mayer have chosen
to translate it as to kiss or often on
the mouth and this has become a very
popular interpretation which would be
quite striking indeed If This Were true
along with the rest of the passage which
indicates that she was His companion and
that he loved her more than the other
disciples seemed to many to indicate
that Jesus and Mary Magdalene had some
kind of romantic relationship now
putting aside mainstream Christian
theology this is of course entirely
plausible a Jewish man of that age would
have been expected to be married indeed
it would have been weird for someone
like that to not be married at that time
but taking into account Christian
Theology and christology this is of
course quite problematic in many
different ways even within an internal
valentinian or Gnostic theology it
doesn't make all that much sense given
that they hold the Dost view that Jesus
wasn't actually truly human others have
translated the passage differently as
kissing her on the hand or the forehead
but given the sentences preceding it it
still poses quite a striking question
about their relationship so how should
we interpret it well this puzzles actual
Scholars on the topic so I won't pretend
to know better than them of course but I
do think it is worthwhile considering
the wider context of the text and its
theme
as we've seen we find the recurring
theme of kissing marriage and the bridal
chamber as symbols of divine ascent and
symbols of divine truth it certainly
seems that these passages indicate that
Mary Magdalene had a special role among
the disciples as the formost one who
inherited the true teachings of Jesus
which like we said is a theme in the
Gospel of Mary as well and while leaving
the possibility that Jesus and her had a
romantic relationship totally open as a
possibility I think we can probably read
this passage in symbolic way too indeed
in another passage it says quote people
are nourished from the promise of the
Heavenly place if they would be there's
a gap here from the mouth from which the
word comes they would be nourished from
the mouth and would be perfect the
perfect conceive and give birth through
a kiss that is why we also kiss each
other we conceive from the grace within
each
other here is a clear indication to me
at least that the true teachings of
which the gospel speaks are conceived or
transmitted perhaps in a way through a
kind of sacred kiss with this in mind I
think it's quite plausible that the
passage talking about Jesus kissing Mary
possibly on the mouth can also be an
indication or symbolic way of saying
that he conferred special knowledge or
gnosis to her especially considering she
was supposedly his favorite among the
disciples whatever the case the Gospel
of Philip remains one of the most
fascinating and puzzling of the
non-canonical Gospels
not only for these famous passages about
Mary but also for its unique language
and imagery involving marriage and the
bridal chamber as well as the way that
it seems to draw from or at least have
similarities with different schools of
early Christianity at the same time from
the sethian gnostics to the valentinians
Thomas signs and the authors of the
Gospel of Mary most Scholars attributed
to a primarily valentinian context and I
am ready to at least carefully accept
that idea but it is certainly a text
that once again shows us the the great
diversity and intellectual melting path
that was early Christianity and all its
different schools and movements it may
not have made its way into the canonical
Bible but it can surely still Fascinate
and Inspire us today in the Contemporary
world thank you as always to all my
patrons who support this Channel and
keep the channel going none of this
would be possible without you and I will
never Tire of saying that so thank you
all so so much might as well take the
opportunity to give a special shout out
to everyone in the Saint category the
highest tier at my patreon um both old
and new some of these aren't even active
still but I would still like to just
mention all these people because they've
been uh supporters at one time or
another and which is so highly
appreciated so thank you so much wasif
Khan while Muhammad Thomas bla Ole
kirovski this guy with all the numbers
and letters soale gokal Faris badawi
Mary Carmen oronas W Osiris Marcel
Wester beak aan zahed Nicholas Kano
prophets Apprentice Abdul kader Shakur
Nash return Ahmed seki Alton khif GMA
Khaled Rosa Brian King Emilio Dominguez
faaz El mubaraki Jordan fredman sanp
Yara Amar Jean squa Dolly Christopher
all coins Flem bra Sam Moreno NORAD a
shangi excuse me if I mispronounced that
Jeffrey ins Kimia meshimar Nadia Leo
Tyson Dany abdullai pangur Carlo Dello I
think John W and Bo Chen thank you all
so so much for the support I would
highly appreciate of course if anyone
else wanted to become Patron this is the
best way to support this Channel and
this mission of giving you free
educational content on the world's
different religions and philosophies and
and cultures and so on it's a project
that I'm very passionate about and I
really appreciate all the help that we
can get uh in that sense so please check
out the patreon page I will leave that
in the description or you can leave a
onetime donation through PayPal as well
also don't forget to check out my new
song isas with my project zeni it's
available in all you know the streaming
platforms and so on I will leave links
to that too in the description if you
are interested and thank you so much for
watching I'll see you next
[Music]
time
n